từ những bạn like stream thách thức nhau trước hàng nghìn người xem khánh sky, hô văn qua và vô quản vướng vọng là liy.
Công ăn tính bất mình đã khởi tổ tạm dạm quyến văn hợi tức khánh sky và hô văn qua về tội cây dối trực công cọng.
Hợi và trên đình tiệp tức vô quản bị khởi tổ về tội, lợi dụng các quyền tự gió dân chủ sâm phạm lợi ít của nhà nước, quyền lợi ít hợp pháp của tổ chức cá nhân.
Vào tối nghe a theo như bị đỏng tốt bọng pháp nơi này. Chúng ta liy mạc sồ chúng ta rởi sửa văn mấy thống để ra kỳ hộ và ràng tiếp như đối.
Theo điều tra băn đầu, sức pháp từ mô thốn trên mạng sở hội, vô bà khánh sky, quà và vô quản đánh nhiều lần sử dụng đại khoản tích tốt để phát chực tiếp, trửi mấy nhau.
Nhưng người này đang tải thông tin xai sửa thật giằm thu hút lợi sêm, tăng tương tác và mở rộn sức an gưởng trên không dạm.
Thông dừng lại ở các buổi live stream trên kái, phán sky và qua còn đến công ty của tích tóc cơ vô qua tại bất nình để tiếp tục phát triệu tiếp về giối chật tự công cậu.
Tại đây, giống khán sky, buông nhiều lời trử bối, đe gióa thách thức.
Mọi gia, công an sách địch, khán sky và vô qua nhiều lần đăng tải các video có lỗi dùng biệt đặt,
suốt phạm dành dự, nhân phẩm của nhau.
Chúng tôi cũng quyến cáo người dân khi tháng ra mạng xe hội, tình cần tôn tục và quyết biệt của phát mọi,
việc chứng thông tin trước khi đăng tải chia sẻ ở mỗi lời.